[Music]  hey Walter is the family coming for  Christmas every single one of them who  is this white man i leakage I'll be  harmless from traveling so I put a  little something together for y'all  milk tea will tapioca balls don't get  balls your mouth baby  oh yes you ungrateful bastards so this  pink pants Malibu Barbie some boyfriend  I got vibrators older than that child  Hey we're not gonna make it to Christmas  are not a damn chance this is our first  Christmas with out your mother just five  days we all to act like a family you  lock me out  you seem to be in a bit of a pickle I'm  trying to get you out of here if nothing  apart if you did sit on Santa's lap I'm  sure everyone at home would love to know  what you would ask for X for a suit that  fits cuz they go mess around and get a  yeast infection  hmm and that cream don't work with  mnsure  [Music]  you've spent your life trying to widen  it